michigan governor gretchen whitmer was
among the speakers at the dnc last night
governor whitmer joins us now from
lansing michigan good morning governor
in this most unconventional of
conventions
what is it that democrats need to do
this week and do you think they did it
last night
i think we kicked it off to a great
start and there are so many phenomenal
speakers but stories and this is the
story of the american people right now
we've got so
many people who are unemployed or
mourning the loss of a loved one or
worried about their health and it's
these fundamentals
that unite us it's these fundamentals
that joe biden and
kamala harris have a plan to address and
i think that's what this moment is
really about
unifying us making sure that people see
that with a plan
we can keep people safe and strengthen
our economy and
and we kicked it off last night and it
was a it was a great start
joe biden is currently leading in the
polls in michigan of course
the president won michigan uh four years
ago
uh but you've said that that you don't
buy it you have doubts why
i just know michigan we will see this
convention this week and then the
republican one next week and then after
labor day i know things will tighten up
they always seem to and so that's why i
don't want anyone to
take anything for granted we've got our
work cut out for us
and covid19 has complicated how we
traditionally do this
but i have a strong belief that joe
biden and kamala harris's
agenda resonates with michiganders who
he is we know him
and he knows michigan and so we have
great confidence that his agenda is
going to ensure that every working
person in this state
and across the country can get ahead and
so
we just can't take anything for granted
and polls really
i mean it's a data point at a moment but
they're all over the place and they will
be through election day
the president won all but two midwest
western states in 2016
democrats take those states back
well in 2016 the president won michigan
by less than 11 000 votes
just two years later i won by almost 400
000 votes we had
a great turnout i think turnout is
complicated in the midst of a global
pandemic and that's why we want to keep
people safe
so if you vote in person we want you to
wear a mask and to be very smart about
doing it so that you're safe and if you
want to avail yourself of mail-in voting
or
voting at home you can start to make
that application on august 20th here in
michigan and we want people to do that
and then drop their ballots off at a
drop-off box
if it gets too close to the election we
were struck by a number
in our new cbs news battleground tracker
poll that found that
74 percent of republicans are very
enthusiastic
about voting in november compared to 66
percent of democrats
does that concern you
i'm going to be concerned about
everything that i see between now and
election day it concerns me when
the head of our federal government uses
the white house to undermine our postal
service
it concerns me when we still don't have
a national strategy around covet
so of course every one of these factors
is concerning we've got to continue to
do the work we've got to continue to
spread the message of
of joe biden and kamal harris but i
believe that
um we will see things tighten up and
we're going to just keep our
our foot on the gas all the way through
election day you were in the running to
be uh joe biden's vice presidential
nominee
and actually traveled today the only
candidate i believe to travel to
delaware to meet with him
uh are you would you consider being in a
joe biden administration have you talked
about it at all
you know one of the things that is so
good about this moment is that i get to
keep the job that i love i'm governor of
michigan you know the best state in the
nation from my perspective my
three generations of my family are here
and i'm happy to continue here
thrilled about it actually and thrilled
that i can vote for someone like joe
biden and kamal harris so
i would never say never to anything but
i would be hard to beat
where i am when it comes to making sure
that i am here on behalf of the people
in michigan and deliver for michiganders
governor whitmer thanks so much for
being with us this morning gail
she's right thank you both never say
never